-We were at an event
and you had some scheme.
You were being crazy.
-Mm-hmm.
-And you wanted to dance wit
Jennifer Lopez.
-Yeah.
-And you wanted me to go ove
and dance with her, too.
-Okay.
We came up with this idea
together, first of all.
We both saw J-Lo --
this is like 10 Jello shots in
And I have never done Jell
shots, I didn't go to college.
-They were good, right?
-Yeah, they were great.
-Thank you.
-And so we were dancing,
we see J-Lo and we're like
"Well, we gotta
ask J-Lo to dance."
♪♪♪♪
-Jennifer Lawrence, you're a
little upset with me.
-Yeah.
-And I think I know why.
But, not really though,
because --
-'Cause we have different
versions of this story.
-I think I'm totally right
with what happened.
-Oh, really?
-That's correct.
-Well, I look forward to
changing that.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, we were at an event
and you had some scheme.
You were being crazy.
-Mm-hmm.
-And you wanted to dance wit
Jennifer Lopez.
-Yeah.
-And you wanted me to go ove
and dance with her, too.
-Okay.
We came up with this idea
together, first of all.
We both saw J-Lo --
this is like 10 Jello shots in
And I have never done Jell
shots, I didn't go to college.
-They were good, right?
-Yeah, they were great.
-Thank you.
-And so we were dancing,
we see J-Lo and we're like
"Well, we gotta
ask J-Lo to dance."
-Yeah.
-And so we were -- I was lik
"Okay, so we'll do..."
-Kanye West was playing.
-...is we'll do a spin...
-Yeah.
-...and then we'll go,
"Dance with us."
like together.
-No, we did a thing, yeah.
-Yeah.
-We had a thing,
we had a routine.
-And then...
-We had a routine.
We were both gonna spin.
-Yes.
-But then we were thinking about
because J-Lo was behind us
-Yeah. Yes.
-Right? She was over there
But we're trying to
work out our moves
without showing her the moves.
-Yeah.
-And we were like, "Alright, w
gotta spin."
-So we both decided on a 360
and then we would hold our -
well, we can't --
the audience is here.
-So, spin, spin out this way
-I don't know if you know
a lot about television, but.
-Thank you, Jennifer.
-And then, "Dance with us.
-And then, "Dance --"
No, that's what you're saying,
but this, again --
Kanye West was on,
it was very loud.
-I didn't know that Kanye West
was playing that night.
-Well, at the time it was
there were digital --
-How many Jello shots did
have?
-No, it was digital,
there was digital
Doberman Pinschers barking
And that's what his concert was.
So you wouldn't know it wa
Kanye West, but yeah it was him.
-Okay.
-It was like [Imitates barking].
And so that was happening.
And that was Kanye.
And then we're trying to wor
out the moves, and again,
-Okay, yada, yada, yada,
basically I do it.
-Mm-hmm.
-And then I go like this,
and I look and he's gone.
[ Laughter ]
And it's just me, looking at
J-lo and going,
"Dance with...me."
And then she was just like -
[ Cheers and applause ]
"No. No!"
because then she was just like
"I think I'm just gonna
observe."
You made me look like a frea
in front of J-Lo,
do you know what
that feels like?
-Oh, stop it!
That's not what happened.
-God.
-Here's what happened.
-Alright.
-I know her manager.
Here we are,
we're working on it.
The dogs are barking at me
[Imitates barking]
And I'm like,
"Here's the plan."
I turn around,
as I'm spinning around,
I see her manager, and I see him
and he looks at me and he goes
"No." So I-I turn the other wa
and you went and I watched
-And you didn't grab me!
-And started dancing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was having fun by myself
a dance party, man.
[Indistinct speech]
"Dance with us," yeah.
So that's what happened.
-Well I wish this manager
had warned me.
-Well, no, you don't even know
the manager.
But so J-Lo, Jennifer Lopez,
if you're watching,
we both did want to
dance with you.
-Just dance with us.
What's the big deal? Right
Come on, we're fun.
-Do some Jello shots.
-Just play us some, like,
barking dogs and dance with us
I mean what's the big deal
[ Laughter ]
-I'll bring the dogs...
-I'll bring the dogs and yeah.
-...you bring the Jello shots.
-Let's make them angry.
-Just dance with us.
-We just want you
to dance with us,
it's very simple.
What do you mean you can't hear?
-I don't ask for a lot.
-You can't hear our voices
over the music?
We want you to dance with us
-Don't we seem like
the kind of people
you'd want to dance with?
-I mean, big deal
our mouths are small.
-[ Laughs ]
-That doesn't affect our
dancing.
[ Laughter ]
I apologize for leaving yo
hanging like that.
-just our social life.
-Just -- yeah, exactly.
I met you -- well, I met you
years ago.
But I met you fairly quickly
at this Met benefit,
back in New York.
-Right.
Yes, I've heard.
I've heard about this.
-With Jennifer Lawrence?
-Yes. [ Laughs ]
-And so it was me
and Jennifer Lawrence
I don't know if you guys heard
this story.
I talked about it once or twice.
-Well, I heard about it
after you guys talked about it
-[ Laughs ]
Well, Jennifer goes, "I wann
dance with J-Lo."
And I go, "Wait, you're talkin
about a J-Law, J-Lo, J-Fal
production?
-Yeah.
This could work!
-So this could work.
So she goes,
here's what we'll do,
we'll start dancing and Kany
was onstage.
-Right, Kanye was about to
perform, actually.
-Was about to perform.
-And everybody was, like,
rushing the dance floor,
if you remember.
-Yes.
-It was like a mosh pit
over there. Yeah.
-Yeah and there was some typ
of music on
and Jennifer Lawrence goes
"I want you, let's spin around
three times, like we're dancin
and then we'll look at J-Lo at
the third spin
and put our hand out and say
"Will you please dance with us?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know, I don't know if I
want to bother --
-I don't love this bit.
-I don't know, I don't want to
bother you, you know, you were
just kinda sitting there.
You were in, like, a booth and
you were next to your manage
and it was all good, and I go,
"Okay."
And then I was like,
I had a few Jello shots,
and I go, "Alright,
maybe I'll --"
-"Let's go for it." Yeah.
-Then I thought, if I go,
"Oh, just go for it."
So then I turned around
and we started dancing and I go,
we did the first spin.
So I did the first spin
and I did the second spin,
and around the third spin it was
like slow-motion,
I saw you and I saw your manager
who goes.
-[ Laughing ] In slow motion
[ Laughter ]
-And I just kept spinning an
Jennifer Lawrence turns around
and goes, "Will you please
dance with me?"
And you were like,
"What is going on?"
-You bailed on the bit.
-I totally bailed on the bit
-That is not okay!
-I ran away.
I acted like I didn't do
anything.
She was so mad to me,
wouldn't talk to me.
-Yeah. Because I remember it
well, too.
You know
because it was you and her
And I was like,
"Oh, there they are."
And I think I was --
was I standing on the couc
to see the performance?
-Yes, that's exactly.
-So you know how you get up on
the club and you're kind o
like on the couch dancing
so you can see everything.
-No, I don't know that at all.
The club? No, yeah.
-You guys know. You guys know,
The Roots know.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Usually when I'm at the clu
I have --
-Oh, you're low key?
-I'm low key, yeah, yeah.
-Not me, I'm like up dancing
and whatever.
So I'm standing up there
and I remember
seeing you guys come over and
remembered Jennifer saying
"Let's go out to the dance floor
and dance."
That's how I remember it.
-Oh, okay.
And not, "Let's go dance."
like out there,
where everybody's dancing,
and I was like,
"No, I'm good. I'm good righ
here." you know and she --
-Yeah.
And you didn't see me at all
-And I kinda felt like she was
sad. Do you know what I mean
Like, she was like, "Oh."
I didn't mean it like that
I just meant, like, it's crazy
out there, it's like a mosh pit.
Like, we can't go out there.
-Well, she didn't talk to me
for, like, months.
I had to talk to her about this.
We talked it out.
-I wouldn't talk to you either
-I know well I --
-You bailed on the bit.
-I bailed on the bit, but
always follow through.
And so I was wondering, tonight,
will you dance with me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jennifer Lawrence,
hope you're watching!
♪♪♪♪